corps l'inquiétude azapo ridja depuis
samedi la centrale nucléaire toujours
occupée par les forces russes
fonctionner uniquement grâce à une ligne
de secours une ligne de 330 kg volts
utilisé pour acheminer l'électricité
vers le réseau problème à la suite de
bombardements un incendie s'est
déclenchée dans une centrale thermique à
laquelle elle est reliée conséquence
cette ligne de secours a été déconnecté
pour éteindre l'incendié ce qui a
débranché du réseau le réacteur numéro 6
le dernier encore en fonctionnement le
cren a informé l'aiea que cette ligne
sert à reconnecter une fois l'incendié
éteint le réacteur numéro 6 continue de
produire l'électricité dont la centrale
a besoin pour le refroidissement et
d'autres fonctions de sûreté nucléaire
pour volodymyr zemsky zaporizhya est
passé à deux doigts de la catastrophe
nucléaire
le bombardement de la centrale montrent
que la russie cet état terroriste ne se
soucie pas de ce que dit la yeux à de ce
que décide la communauté internationale
la russie n'est intéressé que par un
seul fait que la situation reste la pire
possible aussi longtemps que possible ce
mardi l' agence internationale de
l'énergie atomique doit d'ailleurs
publier un rapport sur la sécurité de la
centrale parmi les six experts de
l'agencé arrivé le 1er septembre quatre
ont quitté la zone ce lundi les deux
autres vont maintenir leur présence pour
continuer à évaluer la situation